do you guys think that some of
Littlefinger's name is little
and he's slimy and and do you think like
eel the whole time you like
are there any redeeming qualities about
Littlefinger or even Cersei like you
know that she loves four kids in her
family but we also know that she is the
villain like are there any redeeming
qualities about some of the characters
or are they kind of on point or on those
uh no no we mean redeeming qualities
okay okay
Cersei loves her kids that's the one
thing that you know right here's a
better family but since we're on the
subject speaking of loving kids I gotta
bring something up Catelyn Stark yeah
it's still shooting dirty look seventeen
years later that was the only holding on
like in the first that in the pilot they
made sure to include a scene John like
slowly that's right that was still
exposition that I felt what could have
been done a bit differently yeah he was
a little little I was like okay
obviously she hates now we don't know
why but it's like yeah that's the one
thing that whole thing oh and why is
Jaime's such a jerk did Ned
I don't get that either like they're
both soldiers like why is he Jamie's
just like hey doing Ned you see he's
like the Regina George trying to get the
clown you see some of those in the pilot
we're a bit on nose so that an audience
could grab okay this is the guy it's
because it's so big that's the guy we
need to follow that's a bad guy that's a
good guy there's a lot going on he's a
jerk he's not a jerk do you think he did
that on purpose yeah the cat later on
the pointer was a really really blatant
one and also the audio and they focus on
John and they don't give any time to
Robin Theon you don't find nothing else
there's nothing on ours Robin Theon at
all right like who the good guys and bad
guys are though but could they
differently differently or didn't need
to be that quick for us I think that it
was good the way they did it because I
mean again a lot of attention to
character so
each and every single character you can
tell what their motivations are and what
their aspirations are just by the looks
on their face right right okay they've
done it in a way that was less on the
nose no you had so much exposition you
needed to get out we did it as good as
they could because yeah
think of the the the vissarion the
viserys and danerys conversations they
had to explain home was taken for them
they both want to go back he's been
waiting for 17 years you know the
Targaryen is the rightful heirs you know
he the king says they're not all dead
and then you cut to Daenerys so you know
so yeah I had to get so much you know
and as far as verbal exposition with the
dialogue that that I get because there's
a lot of stuff but with with some of the
shots or some of the characters being so
apparent you know you know Jaime's a
jerk yeah like you know it yeah you have
to I think like the exposit I got
exposition I think that's one of those
David 14 so they do it in a way that
seems very unobtrusive I think it's
totally inclusive really it pulls you
out of the story yeah once you once you
notice it you notice they go see Aquaman
okay and because there's no set up to it
they have to be like back in the day and
these are the seven things and this is
the rule this is the plan and this is
this is what we have to do and it's a
conversation that two people that that
need to that know each other would never
have like you would already know this
you would have ever had this
conversation long ago it's but you know
when the plague designer called it the
Pope in the pool thing it's you have to
dump exposition in a clever way right
and I think that given how much they had
to did that we do a bunch of reshoots
yeah I understand that agree in the
sense that I feel like the way they did
the exposition made sense for each of
the instances so it wasn't just like you
know just some ran in time with someone
was just explaining all these things
again the conversations I think we're
weaved in a way that made exposition
both necessary oh yeah and
understandable they really did a good
job in the showing Sansa at the
beginning she's really really good at
needlepoint so you guys she's a lady and
she's happy with it and then if you pan
to Aria hers is hardly complete she's
like giving Sansa a dirty look and then
she sneaks outside to shoot arrows and
then you get
that she's a tomboy with anything so you
need to show Aria going I don't care
about being a lady and all that stuff
because you just showed it with the
action contrasted right that's what I'm
saying obviously expedition with action
is always the best but that I mean it
was very on the point this Sansa is the
lady and Aria is the tomboy and the
rough and tough kid and did we need to
see it so apparent or could we have
learned that over time some of it you do
learn over time
right but like Ned is it is about to
kill five puppies in the middle like
it's nothing yeah he's a kind and
compassionate father who's just there's
no compunction whatsoever about
slaughtering a bunch of young wolves in
the just just to spare them pain later
so you that's an action that shows who
he is right I see yeah yes they
definitely did just from that they
definitely did exposition perfectly in
this you know they did it in a way that
didn't seem odd or join by any means
just just from that just from watch all
I explained and they did they did it
with gossip too when Jamie shows up
Aria says to Sansa that's the twin
brother right right she's we've shut up
that's another good way so you have
sisters bickering and in there bickering
you show exposition with Jamie and then
I do the same thing with Tyrion when
he's in bed with the prostitute she's
like I heard that he's the son of the
king is a little lecher with
proclivities yeah he's like I'm also
clever and that's another way of showing
it but right they had so much extra get
out and they did a really good job
hiding it right and that's I guess why
over over seven seasons I mean obviously
you get to know these characters and in
a pilot you don't know if it's gonna get
picked up so you have to do it in a the
best way possible and a pilot so that it
does get picked that but when Roberts in
the crypt looking at Liana he's he looks
at her with all this pain as eyes he
says I kill him every night in my dream
yeah so you don't have to have somebody
saying Robert killed Rhaegar in the
field because all you know is that
little piece of information I killed it
I kill him every night in my dreams you
know something something somebody that
hurt her he murdered and that's another
good way of getting exposition out while
also doing something else which is you
know
warning over somebody low right that's a
brilliant way of hiding experiment
yeah yeah they didn't exist exposition
perfectly in this I definitely think so
the numerous brand the king the the
characters I love I love right away as
brand and the reason being is out of all
the star kids he's the I think I believe
the first one we see shooting the arrow
and we know that he is the three-eyed
Raven and we know that he sees all right
and in the first episode we're seeing
through his eyes you know bring bran
with us to the beheading don't look away
you know he's the conduit for us in this
first in this first episode and we are
watching this beheading through a 10
years old to tendril brands eyes not
only that but at the end of the episode
we see this act of incest this
incestuous act through brands eyes right
so everyone like when I first saw so I
was like oh Jon Snow's the protagonist I
thought bran was the protagonist but I
realized to just set up his character
he's the one who sees everything
he literally that's his character so I
love brand right away
I love Daenerys because they show even
in the few scenes that she had they
showed her strength through adversity
you know even though even though in the
scene they kind of show her as being
very subdued and just oppressed yeah
individual and again maybe I'm a little
bias because I've seen her grow
throughout the seasons but I think that
they showed that she's a person who
knows how to show strength through
suffering you know and I always
treasured that in characters characters
who are strong willed and become better
even though SIDS pretty pretty pretty
terrible for them you know that I think
Ned probably and the king the king was a
lot of fun now that you look back at the
pilot John Snow had the classic
all the symbols of the classic
protagonist underdog but you thought
instinctively that it was Ned that was
gonna be the main character for all
eight seasons and he's got the tough
inner complet on conflict man of
principle definitely an accomplished
soldier at the same time and a great
fighter but and the king is just fun
Horace wants to go to the Crypt and his
wife is like well they can wait and he
just completely ignores her and you know
I'm gonna drink my way to an early grave
just admits it but you know that he won
the throne by force so he he's you know
he's a badass at the same time at the
great casting oh yeah and the ball the
performances are grand yeah the actors
that they got in this Lena Headey is
what is incredible is Cersei and you
just hate her and you know Nicolas
coster-waldau is Jamie and you know
Peter Dinklage is great Oh as for the
act the way the acting was done the
performances I keep talking about
Daenerys just cuz she's my favorite
character in this but I'm just saying in
the little scenes that she had there
were moments where they would just show
her face and he could just see you know
her her own inner conflict you could
just see the subtext that she's giving
you just through her eyes and I think
that in terms of performance that's
probably the best I've seen in a while
and she doesn't think she does that in
each episode that she's in so that just
shows the amount like the the amount of
skill that was put into this you know
she lowers herself into the really hot
bath they have the steam coming why is
she doing that oh she can yeah it's a
figure of speech you don't want to like
the dragon you don't want to make me mad
maybe I should start using that line but
I don't know they meant it literally
well it's great in that this season to
just a little touch on that you know she
could get in the scalding hot water and
not be affected by it and you think it's
because she's so scared that she just
wants to numb herself to the pain that
she's about yeah that's not what it is
she's not feeling the heat right she's
she's the blood of the dragon right and
and then you see see the brother get the
the molten gold crown and it burns his
flesh he can't take the heat Emily that
was one of the best best scenes ever and
then afterwards he closes on her and she
says he was no dragon dragon but yeah
that was another good exposition dump
but we were talking about before when
you see Khal Drogo and he just whispers
to her you know no one's ever cut his
hair off because he's never been
defeated
I just want to throw that in there as
the way they you don't see anything from
drill go but you just know cuz you know
that he is his most badass guy he
doesn't say a word except the word no
like but you know do a great job of
setting up characters and you know that
there's so much more beneath the surface
there was a particular attention that I
noticed for Jason Momoa character that
really showed him even though he was in
this very very very few times but it was
just when he was there he felt his
president I think that was done
excellently through score he had tension
or he created attention he created it to
an atmosphere I guess you could say fear
yeah yeah I think that was like this the
way the score was done the way the
settings are made and the way that they
framed him I think that all served that
purpose and it was done to perfection to
be honest good I truly felt like he was
a villainous spirit in that in that
sense no think about this though so many
of the great characters aren't even in
this story yet yeah how Oberyn
yeah you know yeah and the hound is as
mine is pretty much my favorite
character I mean he looks like he's so
unimportant that he's in the background
right now so many of the best characters
you haven't even met yet maybe they had
nose they did that with Daenerys again
they there's a scene where her brother
and some other guy was talking to she
was sitting in the background just
completely out of focus you know if you
notice that they do that quite a bit
what did that mean to you well to me it
showed her how subdued she was her deed
the lack of power that she had and then
as time progresses and she becomes more
strong she becomes more in focus not
only that she becomes more powerful and
you know that dad's little thing I
noticed and I was like wow that that
really shows growth through both
character and story you had a hound -
they they show him when the Fink
the King first pulls up they're just one
quick closeup of him but the hound mass
pulling up his mat just showing you his
face and then a very very quick
conversation with him later with Tyrion
which I didn't even remember happening
right now
but the Hound has more lines than Robin
Theon and then the pilot yeah so they
were they were setting him up to become
something important - yeah and now you
see like oh they did set that up to
become important because if the dragon
eggs aren't gonna hatch why would you
even have them as part of the story to
get the Daenerys right if they were just
gonna hang up on the wall forever now I
realize it should have been obvious that
they were good right but at the time it
was just a wedding game
I kind of felt that that was gonna
happen just cuz I was like okay medieval
times they have eggs oh yeah those are
definitely gonna hatch something's gonna
happen
they can't just let those just beat it
as if something has to pop off yeah Oh
some I'll say that for later
oh yeah okay I don't hate her right away
Jamie I think he's annoying
I hate bullying well you push the little
kid out of the window it's not enough
for you don't know that hey no no that's
true that's true I came to the king yeah
look at this guy yeah that's true I see
disgusting yeah would be more fun to
drink with in a good way Jamie and [ __ ]
my way to an early death come on come on
man what's so great about this you see
this King right up and seriously you
don't know seriously right away the
first image you see of her you know we
see her brute of a husband brush her off
and and well you know I'm gonna go mourn
my long lost love it's like he's a dick
and she has sunset have you bled yet the
third girl she's a political question
pretty much a medical question not to
mention a pretty personal question
political question I think all right in
the beginning these talk politics
differently than I do
but they both got be stabbed that's all
I Cersei and Jaime are the ones that I
don't like even before the last scene
Wow yeah no kidding I can't I can't I
can't miss Sansa not a fan of Sansa I
love songs everyone gives us such a hard
time not talking about the pilot
okay the pot yeah but she's a perfect 14
year old girl I mean not that I know
I've never been a 14 year old girl but
I've had sisters and I'm suppose she's
been primed to be the queen her whole
life she's being married off to the
Prince she's coming into her own as this
young child back then they got married a
lot younger and she's all she can think
about is his boy bands and and cute boys
and that's not our aria is an exemption
different story she's nine her
motivation is much much different he's a
much I guess you could say darker
character innocence where she's not so
prim and proper like her sister is yeah
I like that about in like I think
episode two and she's learning how to
sword fight or dance and he's like what
Ned's like we're gonna we're gonna get
you in some lesson and she's like no
that's not me way might be so self-aware
it's old the truth you know you see the
maturity in the character and that's why
I like her mm-hm
yeah what character do I hate but yeah I
just like the King I think how's it
crazy the Kings awesome yeah but you
could a still calling him I always talk
about just from the first episode of cuz
never mind about say Joffrey gonna lie
to you I actually this is one of those
weird things with me I actually like it
Joffrey
now it's kind of sad when he died cuz I
was like you know dudes is Savage I want
to see somebody go head-to-head with
this guy when he's in a dough
straight-up he would be so heat blowing
every weekly depression with a feather
he's done yeah I wanted to see him I
grew up and be like much stronger they
would actually be nice
coward coward really Oh like that it's
like that type of power they'll be like
a beast no I'm not when the dog attacks
seven he's like blends down and starts
crying and that's why they do like what
14 15 minutes do like a good 28 Brody be
a savage no bread recessive genes he's
gonna be he's gonna be just as much of a
worse as Daenerys he's a bit of a savage
I do unlimited power bro come on
shoppers he was likable at the beginning
right I got that look in his eye like
yeah you look ya Shady yeah I wanted I
wanted him to survive I wanted him to
live and be Wow sandwich those were
things i I don't think he has a savage
bone in his body
you know I hate the the first Ranger who
told everyone to get back on their
horses the first guy that get killed
yeah the first kill that was really the
first kill yours done yeah Matt Damon
didn't he I wonder if he's still like
eight years later he's like I was in the
opening scene of Game of Thrones do you
remember like no you weren't
damn look it up right here no I didn't
like Cersei that was well that was my
number one gang disagree
[Laughter]
that real big scene where Ned is
standing there when cat and mustard
lumen behind him and decide whether a
job Frank
that was the big big fork in the road